ganz Deutschland ist im Griff der
klimakleber so erscheint es und das
Internet ist voll von Videos wie diesem
ich glaube einfach noch nie so nah
alles passiert trotzdem nichts
was machen wir so Angst
bei der Regierung fährt kein Plan
diese Interview diese Videos Interviews
sind ja nicht Mitgefühl in ihn also ein
bisschen Mitgefühl und ein bisschen die
Frage ist das nicht Satire und ein
bisschen das Gefühl also brauchen die
mal ein paar um die Ohren also es ist
tatsächlich sehr gegen körperliche
Zustimmung
nein es ist natürlich es ist ja das gute
Recht junger Leute ideologisch zu sein
und fanatisch zu sein und sich in Ideen
rein zu steigern und so weiter das tun
sie wahrscheinlich immer irgendwie das
machen wirklich das ist keine Satire war
ein Mädchen Pauline filmt ja und ihre
Angst ja vor dem klimawand Angst das
haben wir in Corona gelernt ist auch ein
ideales Erpressungsmittel also mit
seiner eigenen Angst kann man andere
Leute toll unter Druck setzen weil man
darf nicht dagegen sagen das wäre fies
schon was ich jetzt sage ist unheimlich
fies weil ich das nicht ernst nehme ich
ich stehe also ich kann das nicht
beurteilen wie viel Angst sie
tatsächlich persönlich hat ich finde nur
nicht dass sie und andere das Recht
haben alle anderen ihre Angst zu
terrorisieren sondern wir sind hier
immer noch ein demokratischer Staat und
wenn man der Meinung ist es muss viel
schneller viel mehr passieren dann muss
man dafür werben dann muss man dafür
Leute auf seine Seite ziehen die
mitmachen wollen da muss man dafür in
Parteien gehen oder selber Parteien
Gründen und um Mehrheiten werben denn
ich meine diese Klimabewegung muss ich
doch auch selbst ernst nehmen also die
die die die die wissen doch dass es wenn
es so ist wie sie sagen und es so
schnell gehen muss und so doll dass sie
viele Leute zum Mitmachen bewegen müssen
im Moment stoßen sie alle Leute ab und
und Leute wir alle merken in uns dass
wir so irgendwie zu viel drakonischeren
Strafen neigen und und und also
irgendwie das Gefühl haben so kann das
Kinder so kann das wirklich weitergehen
im Dialog wenn sie jetzt im Dialog mit
Pauline werden aus dem Video was würden
Sie Ihr denn entgegnen
naja ehrlich gesagt mir fällt das auch
ein bisschen schwer also das ernst
nehmen also ich finde das ist
pathologisch also das ist wirklich
pathologisch natürlich ist der
Klimawandel etwas was man wo man etwas
dagegen tun muss aber so zu tun als
würde jetzt irgendwie also erstmal kann
Deutschland das nicht alleine das heißt
soll kein Alibi sein nicht zu machen
aber so zu tun als würden wir also zum
Beispiel wenn wir unsere ganze Industrie
killen klar sind wir dann vorbildlich in
unseren Klimazielen die Industrie
produziert nur woanders und meistens
dreckiger